M welcome Council Planning Development
man committee my name is coun Stanley
and chair this committee before we start
the meeting proper can I ask if anybody
present intends to photograph film or
otherwise record the
meeting brilant thank you in any event
we being recorded for live and
subsequent broadcast on the council's
YouTube
channel continuing on to my left and
right to council officers from planning
legal and highways down both sides of
the table and members of the committee
who are all local counselors and
introduce them as they
speak to the agenda item one attendances
to note our attendance as we just have
any apologies we have apologies this
evening from councilors Walsh and
counselor Jerome counc and councelor Le
will be sub thank you counselors we also
have a note councelor Brian he may a few
minutes
late item two Declarations of Interest
members give notice of any personal or
prejudicial interest in the nature the
interest L 20 item on the agenda in
accordance with the accepted code of
conduct does any M wish to declare
interest thank you members item three
minutes to receive and so determined to
approve is a correct record the minutes
of the meeting held on 14th of December
proposer propos thank you second thank
you councelor accepted item four
questions for members of the public we
have none this evening item five
information report to consider report
head of Planning and Development to be
table at the meeting this report has
been so
Ted item six applications for to develop
to consider the TA report to the head of
Planning Development for the listed
applications we have two tonight and the
process is normally the same this case
the item is introduced by me plan if we
have speakers on the item then speak
next members of the public get three
minutes W members get five minutes the
item debate to members of the committee
only
decision by a majority vote I said we
have two tonight members re the the
addition information report the offic
declare on one of those items Ten Club
so the interest of time we'll deal with
the item first then return to the normal
process with you the item on the agenda
so M the reasons for the request for
defer on
987 thank you m yes thank thank you
chair um the applicants confirmed today
that the originally submitted Li of
assessments um that came in with the
scheme uh used some modeling to
represent the boundary treatment um the
model being Spar trees of fencing rather
than the actual bound treatment itself
because that's how that's how they work
but this provided a mitigation of the
light spell impacts um to neighboring
properties but previous applications
which we brought before this committee
and some of you will recall those didn't
take into account any of that boundary
treatment for a good reason because that
boundary treatment isn't in the applican
control it is on the neighbor side of
the fence
um therefore we thought it was necessary
to to request the revised
assessment basically caring out the same
exercise as being done uh previously so
we could understand what uh what the
cumulative impact and uh of of the
proposals was prob the what the non
mitigated impact was um but this does we
had this today uh and it does show
greater spinage of light into the GS of
the laboring properties now that may or
may not be acceptable we need to carry
out the work to understand that um but
we don't know that yet um and we also
need to reconsult neighbors because
there is an increased impact soone that
um they need to be allowed to know about
about that and make representations and
we also need to consult our colleagues
in environmental health who are the
experts in this matter um and therefore
it's recommended that we defer the
application to uh enable that exercise
to be carried out thank you
CH uh thank you m co given the uh the
local high profile this I'm very keen
that we um give the officers time to
make the correct recommendation so I'm
happy to propose that we declare this in
line with M
recommendation second from Council coun
if NOC speak uh it's been proposed and
seconded that we defer this in line with
M C's recommendation all those in
favor uh next agenda is 109 314 two
bwood gardens it's on page 27 of your
Pac and m co will give INR thank you
m thank you chair
um this application is for extensions to
a two-story detached dwelling house on
bwood gens and and it's been reported to
plan committee because more than six
objections have been received contrary
to the officer
recommendation plan the commission sort
the tion two single story side
extensions one on each side of the
property three light roof lights the
front elevation and other external
alterations are proposed but these
elements do not in themselves require
Planning Commission the application had
originally proposed the erection of two
two story side extensions one on each
side of the property a single story
front extension and alterations to the
original roof shape including the front
cable the scheme was significantly
amended on the advice of
officers the key issues to consideration
of the proposal's design impact on
residential emergency and highways and
parking impacts members should however
be mindful of the scope of the planning
application for them the works on the
proposed plans which require planning do
not result in any additional bedroom
accommodation the additional bedroom in
the roof space does not require planning
permission and the conversion of the
garage is not part of the application
thus no EXA additional parking demand
can be attributed to the scheme which is
performed this the evening development
would maintain adequate separation from
laboring properties and would not have a
detrimental impact on their immunity nor
with an appropriate Landscaping scheme
secured by condition would it adversely
affect the Street SE it's therefore
considered that the proposal is in
accordance with policy L7 of the core
strategy and sd4 and as such the
applications recommended for approval
subject to
conditions thank you Mr K we have a
written statement against the
application from the a neighbor Mr Gard
which uh was
um this this is on behalf of the nebor
I'm speaking against the application as
a local resident as I consider the
proposal be detrimental to the area and
fails against the development plan you
will note from the application details
that have been a number of objections
from local residents raising several
concerns about the proposal in reading
through the officer report committee
I've noted that it references parking
provision concluding that the proposal
would not have any unacceptable impact
on parking as a result of the proposed
development however this conclusion is
simply incorrect the officer fails to
acknowledge the development results in
the creation of a further bedroom whilst
acknowledging that the garage is being
converted to a living accommodation and
simply dismisses this in consideration
of The Proposal in line with the
council's supplementary planning
documents spd3 parking standards and
design parking requires three parking
spaces for a dwelling including four
bedrooms this property will have five
bedrooms and no allocated parking
provision this is not acceptable the
property should also provide provision
of four cycle spaces which would
originally been provided within the
existing garage however these have now
been lost by the conversion and are not
rovided on the site the loss of the
garage results in the loss of both cycl
and parking provision with further
issues of two more bedrooms at the
property and no parking Provisions to
accommodate this a five bedroom dwelling
would never be approved no parking space
and I consider it would not be the case
here either the approvement of this
scheme will create excessive on street
parking in an area where there is
already insufficient space putting
children in the area of danger the
proposed fails to provide access to
sustainable travel Alternatives and
fails against the SPD in both regards in
both regards and would not be
contributing towards Trafford council's
aims to promote sustainable forms of
Transport the officer notes that the
citt plans are incorrect and do not
consider the application should have got
to this point in the absence of correct
plans being submitted the overall
extension unbalances the existing
dwelling and is not in keeping with the
Street SE the blank elevations result
the poor overall design the scale and
design of the extensions failing to
reflect any of the design features of
the existing or
surrounding approving a five-bedroom
property with the provision of no
parkings cont to policy and should not
be approved the approval of this scheme
was set a dangerous precedent for future
development the approval of this sche
simply ignoring the council's adoptive
policy thank you m Dr Raymond would you
care to address the committee now yes so
you can forward to the the microphone on
the desk in front of you
there and you'll have three minutes to
speak and we will start the time and
when you begin to speak if you press the
button on the microphone so that we can
we can all hear you so in your own time
thank you don't forget to
press hello than thank you very much for
allowing me to say a few words in favor
of my application I will keep it very
brief and just highlight a few points
number one Trafford Council received my
application for home extension work on
5th of October
2022 and today is the 18th of January
2024 but never mind I'm grateful to the
planning and development officer who has
now recommended this application for
approval since this has been made fully
compliant
with the council's guidance I expect the
committee to approve my application
number two regarding the objections
raised by my neighbors the number is
substantial but it doesn't contain any
tangible matter except for the mention
of loss of green area which will affect
my family more than my neighbors I have
answered all the objections in a logical
Manner and have communicated them
through an email to the responsible
officer so I won't waste your precious
time here on that
reot regarding the issue of car parking
in Rich richet Gardens which has been
mentioned many times by my neighbors it
is not the L lack of parking slots but
it is the result of irresponsible way of
parking CS in that area under discussion
it is worth visiting the area or if you
want I can show you the
pictures
um uh which I have taken with full
precautions maintaining the privacy and
confidentiality of my
neighborhood number four say a very
small minority my neighbors are not bad
people at all but I simply do not
understand their less accommodating
attit attitude in this case one thing is
certain then you the minimum number of
objections to be affected quite
well the last thing to mention is the
commands in the report about my garage
conversion I never converted my garage
detached garage in an unlawful manner I
am a responsible person in health sector
and I would be the last person to breach
the law or go against my statutory
obligations I had consulted the planning
department on two occasions prior to
this garage
conversion and I also went through the
interactive page on the council website
which was highlighted to me by the
planning
department in addition this work has
been overseen by the building Control
Department on regular basis so in this
respect I would hry request to get the
facts right at the end I would thank you
all once again for giving me the
opportunity to speak thank you thank you
Dr rymond I just that by way of
explanation the reason why we said you
can't distribute the photographs is we
have to have thing before the committee
submitted prior to the committee Mee
officers can assess them that's brilant
step away from microphone Dr be
great you can return to the public
area you return the public area sorry
are you return to the public area okay
thank you thank
you uh just for clarity for me Mr could
just just be clear again what the the
the sity in front say ja talked about a
plan commission for a five bedroom house
that's not what us at all is it uh no it
it's it it is it is true that all the
works combined at this property would
create a property with five bedrooms
four in the house three existing one in
the Loft one in the garage that that's
that that's true however this
application doesn't cover that increase
in bedrooms because it's two single
story uh ground floor extensions
additional accommodation ground floor
the Lost conversion is pered development
doesn't mean planning permission could
be carried out um as a separate
operation and that that that would be
fine um and the and the garage the
garage conversion um does did
technically need planning permission but
because of the removal of permitted
development rights from this estate as a
whole um for the purposes of
preventing a trade or business taking
place from the garage not to prevent
those garages being used for living
accommodation so the the reason the
reason for the condition that was
imposed uh which means that there's have
been a technical breach of PL of control
but one that we don't think is expedient
to enforce against is to prevent injury
to the immunities of the surrounding
residents due to noise and disturbance
likely to be caused by the establishment
of a commercial use in the development
having regard proposal D1 of the revised
tra development plan which was
development plan which was enforced at
at that time so the planning harm that
was alleged from the garage conversion
was a reduction in parking spaces well
we have to think about two things about
expediency at that point would would
taking action uh address the planning
well it wouldn't because we can't force
somebody to put car in a garage and also
what was the purpose of the Restriction
in the first place it wasn't about
parking it was about um immunity so for
those two reasons uh there's there is no
good reason to enforce it so we come
back to what's in front of members the
evening which is two single story side
extensions at ground floor no additional
bedrooms so when you're making your
decision you're considering whether this
whether those extensions are appropriate
um and that the net increasing um
parking requirement at this at this as a
result of these proposals is is nil
thank you M over
this thank you chair I've got a question
as well on the plans it shows um
converting The Loft
into um a living space a bedroom space
yet the dimensions don't look um high
enough walk around and they're too
short
yeah yes um we we asked our building
control colleagues um about this Al be
it uh I believe that the applicant is
using private build control which is his
his entitlement um the the staircase
will be very slightly short but that's a
matter for the applicant to comply with
the building RS and and to get that sign
off um and it again shouldn't form any
part of your consideration this evening
you should assume that other
other regulations legislation work as it
is anticipated and there are other ways
of dealing with it such as lowering
salings you know it's not not the only
way dealing with
that thank you Council thank you m
Council thank you chair um first of all
um thank you for you know what you just
mentioned because these were you know my
questions but you've already answer it
and based on what you know heard you
know from the applicant and the report
it's very clear to me that
all the necessary requirements have been
met you know the application on balance
if we were to go
otherwise against the office a
recommendation I suspect that you know
an appeal um it will be allowed so I'm
happy to propose that we go the officer
recommendation and R
application thank you coun
coun thank you question as well so one
of the points that's made in the
representation is about being very C AG
in the laws of um properties in the
immediate vicinity obviously this uh
this
proposal is will be on a larger Flor um
footprint and I wondered about whether
what action would be taken or needs to
be taken or needs to be considered in
terms of surface range and potential
impacts of the extension on
it yes say that yes certainly um for
house extensions again we uh would would
uh generally and in this case uh look to
building regulations to deal with that
again um because uh appreciate I
appreciate the points being made that
you've got more hard surfacing when
where you've had greeny before that but
in overall terms that would be
considered to be dominous you're
draining into the same um surface and
fou water system that you've already got
for the the estate um and that that
connection will be dealt with through
the building regulations it's not like
where you've got a new
or a um or a larger development which is
putting a whole new connection into or
building a new network at which point we
would we would also consider that in
terms of planning and the Greenfield
runoff and that kind of thing this is
not of a scale where where we would
consider we need to need to deal with
that um as we said as say it's dious in
terms of its surface water
impact uh Council
I don't see any planning reasons to say
to refuse it so I'm I'm more than happy
to Second proposal to um to gr the
application
lineation okay thank you councelor uh if
no one else wishes to speak then it's
being proposed second that we approve
this allow Au recommendation all those
in favor
now that's few thank you
I think that concludes the um the what
you might call the public part of the
meeting and we've got a couple of as
we've got some time here we've got a
couple of uh items that we'd like to
just to chat about for about 10 minutes
one of them is places for everyone and
one of them is the uh the proposed
planing on the first plan training on
the
first
J yes youn okay thank you so much
thank
I